Hey YouTubers, it's Charlie. This is gonna be my Arrow episode 21 video.
Lots of comicbook stuff we have to work through, including the person that might end up being the season 4 villain.
Just this big rumor that was going around a couple of months ago
was that the finale would tee up who the season 4 villain is going to be
and they basically called him out in this episode
so careful for spoilers if you haven't seen 21 yet
Starting with top 5 moments. Number 5: meet Damien Darhk, probably gonna be the Arrow season 4 villain.
So, as Rha's Al Ghul was like slowly brain washing and training Oliver using the fear toxin from Batman Begins no less
he explains that Damien Darhk was a person who joined the League the same time he did
but ended up hopping on the crazy train and created a splinter organization to carry on the League's work as he saw it
Rha's tasks Oliver with taking Damien down. This is just the beginning.
Damien Darhk is actually a character from the Teen Titans comics.
I know everyone always asks about the Titan show that's happening on TNT
They've actually changed the name of that show, it's not called Titans anymore, but I'll talk about it in another video.
Damien debuted in Titans nº1 in 1999
He really only existed inside that arc, it was like a 12 issue arc
So, in issue number 12 he ended up being killed by Vandal Savage
He hasn't appeared in the new 52 comics
But he is a big H.I.V.E. character and he gets tied up with Slade Wilson's wife
Her name is Adeline Kane so, if they're gonna be doing Damien Darhk-H.I.V.E. in season 4
it'd be an easy way to bring Deathstroke back on the show
and they said they can do that. Even though the Suicide Squad movie might be doing Deathstroke
they can still put him on the show, they can still bring Manu Bennett
So they tie Damien Darhk to all these past events on the show, like trying to buy the prototype of Merlyn's earthquake machine
and killing Diggle's brother
They'll continue to do that, and what I'm hoping that they do
is that they tie him to Felicity, he ends up being Felicity's father
In the comics, Damien's known for his baby-face
I don't know how the show's going to address this, because
supposedly only Rha's Al Ghul has access to Lazarus pit
So we might see the same kind of thing going on with Damien, he might just be like a really old person in a young person's body
Moving on to number 4: Oliver-League of Assassins training montage
I really like the way they shot the opening scene, just like cutting over the course of a couple weeks
Oliver slowly gets brainwashed with the fear toxin, and gets really badass with swords
They're not only brainwashing him, they're also training him to fight
Even though Team Arrow seemed like they'd almost given up on him by the end of the episode
there is no programming that cannot be broken somehow
Something is going to happen to redeem him at a certain point
Whether or not they carry it into season 4 we have no idea
I always like how they try to trip you up with like an opening moment WTF
like him stabbing Diggle, but then it turns out it's someone else
Great way to start an episode, make everyone poop their pants
On to number 3: Laurel and Nyssa are milkshake gal pals
I really like the way they developed a friendship between those two characters
Nyssa is such an awesome character so I'm just happy to have her on the show
I think it's a good way to humanize her and give Laurel a really nice arc that has absolutely nothing to do with the rest of the team Arrow
Like they can just have their own scenes off on their own
Mostly Nyssa trying to train her the same way she trained Sara
That's gonna take a long time but now that she has the canary cry
I think she'll learn to use that, too, and it'll help close some of that distance
It's just really interesting dichotomy they had between Oliver and Nyssa
Whereby, she slowly gains her humanity and Oliver is like losing his at the same time
It's too bad they captured her at the end of the episode, because
I was kind of hoping she'd join team Arrow, like the new team Arrow for a little while
I definitely have to give Laurel props though for being the voice of reason
It's like everybody is losing their shit except for Laurel
She's kind of like the moral conscience of team Arrow right now
Moving on to number 2 though: Oliver kidnaps Lyla and threatens her life
I don't think we were ever in any danger of Oliver killing Lyla
but it's still really heartbreaking to see him go up against his Arrow bro, Diggle
Lyla had that really nice speech about how joining team Arrow helped humanize Diggle
Like after the war he was suffering from post traumatic stress
but Oliver helped give him a purpose
It seems like it's all falling on deaf ears right now
but, I think at a certain point something will happen to shock Oliver back to consciousness
and if you're wondering, all those team Arrow scenes where they were meeting
that was inside Ray Palmer's lab
That's gonna be like the temporary Arrow cave
You can call it the ATOM cave if you want
Eventually Ray will step in and help out
but he wasn't really necessary for this episode
It was mostly about classic OG team Arrow vs Oliver
And of course, my number 1 WTF moment: Rha's Al Ghul tells Nyssa that she is now the bride of the Demon
and asks Oliver to unleash the Omega on Starling
You can kind of see how we're drifting into Christopher Nolan-Batman territory here
"Destroy the city, wipe it clean"
I like how he just casually dropped that the previous Rha's Al Ghul, his predecessor, wiped out Alexandria
Like a biblical plague
There was kind of a bible moment where he asks Oliver to kill Nyssa
It was like when god asked Abraham to kill his son Isaac
And then when he went in to do it, god stopped Abraham and said "No, this was just a test, and you passed"
Bride of the Demon though, all I could think about
was like the Bride of Frankenstein's scream when Elsa Lanchester just screams out loud with the crazy hair
Mark Guggenheim did tease that there would be another wedding on Arrow this season
that wasn't Diggle's
I think we'll see some kind of ceremony, don't expect it to actually go down
I don't think they'll make it to the vows
Hopefully it'll actually go down in next week's episode
that's what I'm looking forward to
It's like, next week we deal with the wedding stuff and then the week after that, we deal with the Omega-Starling stuff
That really only scratches the surface of the episode
but here's my big question for you guys
How do you think that team Arrow is going to help Oliver shake his programming?
Whatever they end up doing, it's gonna be something that they have to do together
Like it'll be all of them together in the same moment
If you remember in the mid-season finale, when Oliver died, all those images flashed through his brain
I wonder if the same type of thing is gonna happen, like what if he ended up dying and they dump him in the Lazarus pit
and he comes out changed
that'd be pretty crazy. Remember, this last scene in this episode
they were standing in front of the Lazarus pit
So, I feel like the Lazarus pit is gonna continue to be a big plot point
before season 4
Somebody else needs to get dumped in there
Speaking of the Lazarus pit, let's talk about Thea for a second
So, Felicity tells her that Roy's still alive, so obviously she's gonna track him down
we saw him in the promo for the next episode
Don't really know if Roy's gonna be in the finale, but  he's probably gonna help her on
road to becoming a superhero
She's slowly moving towards the Mia Dearden's Speedy
She's not gonna change her name or anything, I don't know exactly what her final costume will look like
but she was wearing a hood in this episode, so she's like halfway there
She'll probably just get a mask like they all wear
Which also actually brings up the idea of a Diggle costume
"Don't say the word costume"
Felicity just teased that he should start using some more identity concealment if he's gonna be hitting the streets more often
I know everybody wants to see Diggle get a costume, but he's not gonna get a costume
It'll just be like slightly more secure gear
I will say, my only minor complain about the episode was the plot point about the Alpha-Omega with the flashbacks
It's been like such a huge thing all season long
with the flashbacks
but they just now tied it back to present day
I think the flashbacks work a little bit better when, you know, scene to scene flashback to present day within each episode
sync up more
The flashbacks this season felt a little uneven
As you can see, the shit hitting the fan on both flash and arrow
Grodd is coming to The Flash next week
So be sure to subscribe to get that video
A lot of you requested a Speedy bonus video
so I'll try to get that out as soon as possible
maybe next week, or at least the week after
While you guys wait for all that stuff, in case you haven't seen it
I just posted an Agents of SHIELD - Avengers crossover video
you can click here to watch it
and you can click here for this week's episode of the flash
Thank you so much for watching, everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tomorrow